we will now embark on what is probably
my least favorite exercise or
computation in mathematics and I think
you'll see why where we will invert a 3
by 3 matrix and and in my mind the only
thing less pleasant than inverting a 3
by 3 matrix is inverting a 4 by 4 matrix
it very quickly becomes obvious to you
that it's probably better for a computer
to do this but you need to learn how to
do it and it's it's a good exercise for
me to do and if I keep doing it my whole
life it'll it'll prevent my brain from
degrading but as you'll see this is
almost an exercise and not making
careless mistakes so let's start with a
3 by 3 matrix and try to take the
inverse so let's say I have matrix a I
think I'm gonna need a lot of space here
so I'll try to do this small without
being confusing matrix a say it's 1 0
and I'm specifically choosing this
matrix because the numbers are
reasonably non hairy 0 2 1 1 1 1 so the
first thing that I do when I take an
inverse of a 3x3 matrix I could create
what I call or without what I call what
everyone calls a matrix of minors so let
me say with that let me write that down
matrix of minors matrix of minors matrix
of minors so what's a minor well what a
minor is is let me just let me draw that
out so it's going to be another 3 by 3
matrix and what it is so this element of
this top-left element is essentially
going to be the determinant if I were to
take if I were to take my original
matrix and I were to cross out the top
the dispositions row and column so for
example if I were to quote for this 1 1
position Row 1 column 1 I cross out Row
1 and column 1 and what numbers do I
have left I have this 2 1 1 1 I have
this right here so it's the determinant
of 2 1 1 1 and actually maybe I'll
that down so it's the determinant of 2 1
1 1 so this it's I'm gonna run out of
space I'm sure it's gonna be 2 1 1 1 the
determinant right the absolute value
sign says its to determinate remember
all I did is I said okay in position 1 1
let me cross out the row sorry the
column and the row 1 1 and take the
determinant of what's left or the minor
of this matrix right and then I will
take the determinant so when I go to
this position I'm in kahlan Row 1 column
2 so Row 1 column 2 I'm essentially
going to take the determinant if I were
to cross out Row 1 and column 2 across
that Row 1 column 2 what I have left
over I have 0 1 1 1 so it's 0 1 1 1 it
might be confusing but just remember I
wish I had something I could cover this
with unfortunately my my fingers can't
show up on this video but if you cross
this row and this column out your stuff
with this 0 this one this one and this
one and you take the determinant of that
minor and then we keep going I'm
probably going to run out of space here
but I will try my best and so when you
go to this position Row 1 column 3 what
do you do well you cross out Row 1
column 3 and then the determinant or the
minor that you have to do is 0 to 1 1 0
to 1 1 the determinant of 0 2 so the
determinant of that 1 by 1 matrix a 2 by
2 matrix and then you keep doing that so
forth and so on and I'm going to run out
space but what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to calculate it I think you
understand how to do it well you don't
understand how to do it but I think when
we calculate it'll make a little more
sense so let me actually just calculate
it out because if I were to write these
2 by 2 matrices I would run out of space
but anyway let's go back to this
position 1 1 cross out the first row
first column I want the determinant of
this thing right here so what's the
determinant of this 2 by 2 that's not
too hard it's 2 times 1 minus 1 times 1
right so what's 2 times 1 minus 1 times
1 well it's just 1 then when we go to
Row one position
column two I want the determinant of 0 1
1 1 so it's 0 times 1 minus 1 times 1 so
0 times 1 is 0 minus 1 times 1 is minus
1 alright and that's just this
determinant right here I just I'm just
kind of rish owing you how I visualize
when I cross out the rows and columns so
0 times 1 minus 1 times 1 and in this
position of course you cross out this
row this column and 0 times 1 minus 1
times 2 so that's minus 2 minus 2 let's
keep going alright so now when we're in
row 2 column 1 we cross out Row 2 cross
out column 1 and we're left with this 0
this 1 this 1 and this 1 so it's 0 times
1 which is 0 minus 1 times 1 so we're
minus 1 minus 1 then when we got row 2
column 2 we cross those two out and we
take the matrix of the minor that's left
so it's 1 times 1 right minus 1 times 1
so that's 0 almost we're halfway done
ok so then we're in row 2 column 3 so we
cross out Row 2 column 3 and what we
have left is 1 times 1 minus 1 times 0
so that is just one last row okay so
we're in Row 3 column 1 so we cross out
Row 3 column 1 you have left with 0
times 1 is 0 minus 2 times 1 so that's
minus 2 minus 2 then we're in Row 3
column 2 so we cross out Row 3 column 2
and you have 1 times 1 minus 0 times 1
so that's just one last one Row 3 column
3 so we cross out Row 3 we cross out
column 3 and you're just left with 1
times 2 minus 0 times 0 so that is 2
I haven't made any careless mistakes
that is our matrix of minors or yeah
matrix of minors that's what I would
call it now we now have to convert this
to a we call the matrix of cofactors and
actually this step is fairly
straightforward so to convert from a
matrix of minors to a matrix of
cofactors you just have to remember this
pattern and this pattern applies to any
3x3 matrix plus minus plus minus plus
minus plus minus plus and so you can
kind of just imagine this as kind of a
checkerboard of pluses and minus and you
apply that to this so what do I mean by
that well that means I'm going to take
so I knew start as this checkerboard and
you start with a plus at the top left
and then you just keep alternating plus
minus right so if you apply this to this
you get the matrix of cofactors of
cofactors let me write that down
matrix of cofactors matrix of cofactors
the matrix of cofactors you can manage
this is a bit of a marathon of
computation okay so the matrix of
cofactors is essentially applying this
pattern to the matrix of minors so what
do you do you say this plus 1 times 1 is
1 but now we have a minus right so it's
minus times minus 1 it's positive 1
then if plus times minus 2 is minus 2
then you have a minus here minus times
minus 1 is positive 1 plus times 0 is
still 0 - what - times 1 is minus 1 plus
times minus 2 that's minus 2 minus
applied to 1 is minus 1 and then plus
applied to 2 is just 2 and we have our
matrix of cofactors and we are more than
halfway done with inverting this matrix
and I just want to take a note here what
we're doing it's you know it's kind of
just a magic formula it might seem a
little bit like voodoo for you but I
just want you to keep in mind that in
future videos I will show you where this
comes from all the
we'll be quite hairy to prove it for a
three-by-three but I'll definitely show
it to you for a 2x2 and actually I'll
show you other algorithms where that
might make a little bit more intuitive
sense for doing it for 3x3 but I just
wanted to show you how to do it this way
so that at least you know when you see
it on your algebra 2 exam because they I
you know I think they actually teach
this an entrepreneur teacher asks you to
solve for the matrix of minors or the
cofactors or solve for the determinant
of the inverse you can do it and then
we'll worry about getting the intuition
which is not how I normally like to
teach things but this is an exception
but anyway back to the problem this is
the matrix of cofactors now from this we
take the adjoint of matrix a or I
learned from Wikipedia the correct term
is the adjutant of matrix a but this is
it's determined the notation is the
adjutant of a and all this is is the
transpose of the matrix of cofactors and
I know I'm throwing out a lot of weird
terminology here but the transpose all
that means is that you switch the rows
and the columns so this is in this one
right here is in Row 1 column 1 so now
it's going to but you know so the rows
and the columns are the same so that
just stays the same so it actually
anything on the diagonal stays the same
because this is Row two column two this
is Row three column three so the the
diagonals today the same and then you
switch places you kind of flip across
the diagonal and now what do I mean by
that well this one this one was in Row
one column two right this one is in Row
one column two so it'll then be moved to
Row two column one so this one right
here will go here so you can kind of say
that it flipped it flipped over the
diagonal right and similarly this right
here is in Row one column three it's
going to be switched to Row 3 column one
so it's going to go here right and you
can kind of see that it just flipped
over that end so this minus two isn't
this one it's this one
over here and actually we see that this
matrix is symmetric when you flip it you
actually get the same thing so maybe it
was a bad example but I want you I want
you to understand that the transpose is
where you if something is in row you
know like this number if it's in Row one
column two then it moves to Row two
column one so you're switching the rows
and the columns but anyway we could keep
doing that but essentially you're just
flipping over the diagonal so let's see
so then this number will be flipped to
this position so it goes there
right this is in Row two column one so
we'll go to column two Row one which is
that and then if we go here that's going
to be flipped down here flipped across
the diagonal so this is minus one this
is going to be flipped all the way up
there so it's minus two and then this
will be flipped there this is minus one
we are almost done so this is the
adjoint of matrix a so to get the
inverse of a and let me actually erase
some of this just because we're going to
run out of space otherwise and as you
can see that this is I'll be very
impressed if I have not introduced a
careless mistake yet
so the create I'll erase all of this I'm
building an appetite just doing this
problem it's so taxing on me so the
inverse of matrix a the inverse of
matrix a is equal to 1 over the
determinant of a time's the ad you get
or the adjoint of matrix a
well we solved for this part so now
let's solve for let's solve for the
determinant so the determinant of a and
I kept the matrix of cofactors here for
a reason
the determinant of a is if you go across
you could actually go across any row but
you just for simplicity just remember
this way you go across the top row and
you multiply each term times its
corresponding cofactor and you add them
so in this case it'll be 1 times its
corresponding cofactor which is 1 plus 0
times its corresponding cofactor which
is 1 plus 1 times its corresponding
cofactor plus minus 2 so this is 2 then
I'm sorry this is 1 plus 0 minus 2 it
equals minus 1 and thank God it was a
relatively straightforward determinant
and if you didn't have this matrix of
cofactors the other way you could think
about it and this is good because it
gives you an intuition of how we even
got to the matrix of cofactors you could
view this as this is the same thing as 1
times its might the determinant of its
minor so if you cross out the row in the
column it's this determinant so it's 2 1
1 1 and then remember there is that
pattern you have plus and then you go
minus so minus 0 times the determinant
of its minor so you cross out that row
that column so 0 1 1 1 0 1 1 1 and then
we go we alter switch again we go back
to plus plus 1 times the determinant of
its minor so you cross out
Road that communes ero to 1 1 0 to 1 1
and you could compute this out and I
mean these this and this is this
cofactor this with a minor sign of like
this is just the minor right and then
when you apply the minus sign it becomes
this cofactor and then this is that
minor and since the plus sign there
that's that cofactor but anyway I just
wanted to explain that and hopefully
hasn't confused you but we're ready now
to solve the inverse of a we know that
the determinant of a is equal to minus 1
we know that the adjective a is this
number here so we now can solve for the
inverse and let's do that let me erase
all of this stuff because actually after
I solved for the universe I want to
prove to you that it is the inverse
maybe if I have enough time cuz I just
realize that I'm running pretty long
that might be a good exercise for you ok
so the inverse of a a inverse is equal
to 1 over the determinant we figured out
the determinant is negative 1 times the
adjutant of a1 1 minus 2 1 0 minus 1
minus 2 minus 1 2 so this is just minus
1 right so we just apply Multan times
everything so we get if I haven't made
any careless mistakes minus 1 minus 1
plus 2 minus 1 0 1 2 1 minus 2 I think I
think that I have let's see I just did a
minus times everything that looks right
and so that is a inverse and it only
took us 17 minutes and I will leave you
there because it probably take me
another 5 or 10 minutes to see if
improve but that might be a good
exercise for you to multiply this matrix
times this matrix and make sure that you
get the identity matrix I will see you
in the next video